driving into a tot a village which is
inside the exclusion zone created by the
Fukushima nuclear disaster you don't
really immediately notice anything out
of the ordinary I mean you see houses
and shops and everything you would
expect to see in a Japanese village and
there aren't any clues that this has
been the site of the worst nuclear
disaster in twenty-five years or so the
only way you really know is when you
look at your Geiger counter and here the
one I was using shows a reading that's
about roughly 10 times the natural
background depending on where you are in
the world this is not enough to make you
sick right away but this is definitely
enough that you wouldn't want to be
living in this area anymore which is why
it's been evacuated by the Japanese
government when you get out of the car
you really start to feel that there's a
difference here things are very quiet
the curtains are drawn in all the houses
and one of the first things we saw was
this dog she had been left by her owners
because her owners couldn't take her to
an evacuation center and so they did
what a lot of people in the Atatu
village have done they chained her up
and they leave food and water for her
and come back a couple times every every
week to refill the food and water and
basically she's left to her own devices
the longer you're in the exclusion zone
the more you really start to notice
these subtle differences you see rice
paddies that have been completely
overgrown you see farm buildings that
are empty all the livestock was
slaughtered at the time of the accident
basically out of fear of radioactive
contamination and you do see some other
signs of human activity this is the only
piece of graffiti I saw in my entire
trip to Japan the first symbols there
are for TEPCO the Tokyo Electric Power
Company which was responsible for the
meltdown and you see security personnel
protecting the even more dangerous
exclusion zone beyond D today so we
drove right up to the gate the furthest
week ago and that was still about 30
kilometers from the plant there's a
plume of radiation
that came to the northwest and that's
why I taught I had to be evacuated the
other people you would see inside the
exclusion zones were cleanup crews and
you would see these these groups of
people scraping away the top few inches
of soil to remove the contamination
because in fact the contamination
doesn't go very deep into the earth they
were sort of little by little clearing
away the the topsoil and putting it into
these bags that were then piling up all
over the prefecture and it's still not
clear where all these bags of
contaminated soil are going to go after
visiting the Tata village the next day
we drove to new raha town which is a
town inside the exclusion zone to the
south of the plant and directly on the
Seacoast and what we saw there was very
different people hadn't been able to
clean up the tsunami damage so in other
parts of Japan coastal Japan I visited
you would barely even know a tsunami had
happened but here there were still
ruined cars and houses the flood plain
was completely washed out roads have
been washed out and hadn't been repaired
and I guess to me this is really what
the nuclear disaster at Fukushima is all
about is that this this cleanup hasn't
happened people haven't been able to
move on with their lives
you